i think that the people at the mosque
were very nice and i'm glad that
muhammad will have a muslim community
here
but a part of me is worried that he'll
expect me to convert to islam
so
that makes me feel a little
uncomfortable
oh my god that was crazy
they're all very nice and welcoming and
who knows maybe this is the first step
for you to convert to islam
i
don't have any plans of converting
[Music]
i'm really disappointed that eve doesn't
want to convert to islam
because she still
doesn't understand the culture and i was
very open with eve from the very very
beginning about what i expected from her
about her clothes and stuff like that
know that i will always support
you wanting to have a religious life in
whatever religion you choose but i want
the same
she has to sacrifice these things for me
because i wouldn't marry any person who
doesn't prioritize my needs
and maybe she
need to become a muslim
for this relationship to
to work out
[Music]
[Music]
you